six weeks later I can't wait to see how
those are going really interna
for how are you well thank you well they
will she screamed no you had a dream
about me last night
I thought you two may know David I
killed you you're not wrong there you
know yeah when I first visited I found
chef ko kata Alex Scott living in a
dream world he believed he was a
talented Italian chef but his kitchen
was kiltie own and said that wasn't
regular the food was dire and overpriced
I've been disgusting and to make matters
worse his restaurant manager Gavin was a
wimp Hugh as a Maitre D' are [ __ ]
useless no wonder Alex was drowning in
debt
and about to lose his home and his
business never work by the tear so close
to cowboy
yeah after a week of hard slog Lanterna
was reinvented and given the potential
become a great neighborhood restaurant
clerk that swordfish beautiful now I'm
back to see if my time at Lanterna had
any lasting effect
excuse me you don't walk in a after the
way you shouted at me so I thought
Leisha [ __ ] make a bit of presence oh
yeah no powder oh you can call that it's
crap come on [ __ ] [ __ ] have you
been [ __ ] to moles we [ __ ] hanging
around waiting for you you lazy [ __ ]
bastard how I thank you good to see well
that's better
excellent where's L Donna's Christmas
tree vegetables they all stack they've
all gone now do malt order anything
stunt order thank god those revolting
overcook vegetables are off the mains
overall the whole stuff infusions lifted
I knew look cleaner
shall we nails not bad I'm gonna duck in
the car wash with three yes oh I feel
real you know refresh reinvent I'm happy
about what I'm doing
young cleaner forget son everyone can't
believe what I'm seeing
you get straight down John Odom door
show me surprised me Alex yeah that's
not bad
so what's that in there that's my mix my
own table such as [ __ ] me [ __ ] made
serious I'm speechless
alex is actually cooking up acetone here
we have it ravioli filled with mushrooms
and nada Jesus Christ [ __ ]
you were hot yeah he surprised me
I suppose me um yeah yeah a little bit
still no survivors
in shock thank you I do think you're
capable of doing it the amount of
someone's been in the kitchen now is I
take about four hours more to what I was
doing and the more work an fo and more
care you put into food the more it hurts
when it goes wrong well absolutely
so you know it's an interesting
relationship and it looks like you've
now started to sort of really wake up
and understand that bond with food each
time I make the ravioli I can be proven
every time I'll see tasting the food is
it's better than using the fresh
ingredients why we've told the talk yep
now we'll eat the [ __ ] food okay yeah